how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel there is
something really really big happening in
the MCU right now revolving around
spider-man and not Tom Hollands
spider-man even though we love him but
around Tobey Maguire spider-man there is
a very very good chance that if certain
events take place and happen within the
next couple of months that Tobey Maguire
spider-man could make an appearance in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe now this
is obviously something that people have
wanted for a pretty long time now
especially after in spider-man 5 from
home Mysterio mentioned the multiverse
now of course that wasn't real Mysterio
was lying but now we know the multiverse
is going to be real and a part of the
MCU thanks to dr. strange and the
multiverse of madness and now thanks to
some recent developments it does seem
like we could be seeing Tobey Maguire on
screen once again to reprise his role as
Peter Parker spider-man so let's break
it all down if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things relating to the MCU and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or ps4 picking a winner
at five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers so most of you have probably
heard the news scott derrickson who
directed the first Doctor Strange film
and was hired and brought on board to
direct the second one is no longer
directing it scott derrickson and Marvel
have parted ways and he's still going to
be an executive producer but no longer
directing Doctor Strange too in the
multiverse of madness but now it's been
reported by pretty much every media
outlet that you can possibly think of
that Sam Raimi is currently talking with
Marvel Studios and is in negotiations
with them to direct Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness now if you're
unfamiliar with who Sam Raimi is he
directed the very first spider-man
trilogy and the ones with Tobey Maguire
well it looks like he is now about to
come on board to direct Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness and if Sam
Raimi does in fact come on board and is
the director of multiverse of madness
that's almost a guarantee that we're
going to see Tobey Maguire spider-man in
some shape or form because what if I
told you that Sam Raimi had been
planning on a spider-man and Doctor
Strange crossover since 2004 spider-man
2 way before the MCU even existed
because that is exactly what he was
planning in fact he was the first one to
reference that there is a big
marvel universe out there one that
exists with many different superheroes
in it and he even named drops Doctor
Strange and spider-man - that's crap
science squid crap Doctor Strange that's
pretty good it's taken fans have
personally wanted Sam Raimi and Tobey
Maguire spider-man to enter the MCU in
some way shape or form and fee directs
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness a film where a bunch of
different multiverse exists it's pretty
much guaranteed that we're going to be
seen Tobey Maguire spider-man which is
absolutely fantastic news and for those
of you who are worried that Scott
Derrickson was going to make Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness a
horror film
don't worry Sam Raimi has plenty of
experience there he's got plenty of
experience directing horror films in
fact he created and directed Evil Dead
The Evil Dead - army of Darkness at the
quick and the dead
and dragged me to hell and this is most
likely why Marvel is eyeing him and is
currently in negotiations with him to
direct multiverse of madness because he
has that previous experience plus he's
worked with Marvel before even though
back then when he directed these
spider-man movies it was under Columbia
Pictures and Marvel enterprises but
nonetheless he's worked with Marvel
before and he has experienced directing
horror films that combined with the fact
that we will most likely get Tobey
Maguire spider-man in Doctor Strange and
the multiverse of madness if Sam Raimi
ends up being the director makes him the
absolute perfect candidate to direct a
film so let me know your thoughts on
this would you like Sam Raimi to direct
Doctor Strange and multiverse of madness
and would you like Tobey Maguire
spider-man to make a cameo in the film
as well let me know what you think in
the comments down below and don't forget
to like this video and subscribe when
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof